hi in this video I'm going to talk about
the difference in imaging property of
our confocal and our wide field
microscope that means a good quality
pure sense microscope on the left-hand
side you can see the image of white
field fluorescence microscope and point
to be noted that in our fluorescence
microscope it's very costly and it has
optical sectioning property and that
means it has a motorized stage and our
confocal also have that particular
property additionally our confocal have
the pinhole and lasers
so the imaging property of these two
microscopes are quite different you can
see from that particular image now we
are in a particular focal plane xxiii
optical sectioning we are in the 23rd
focal plane and you can see there is a
lot of details in the confocal image
compared to the wide field now let's get
deep into the specimen into the deeper
focal plane you can see in the white
field we are getting no information all
the information are lost in the blur but
on the right hand side you can see in
the control you can see the sharp and
crisp image of this particular pollen
grain now comes the scanning speed of
the laser in the confocal microscope and
in Whitefield you don't need laser so in
the scanning speed of Orkin focal
microscope you have to be conscious
about your scanning speed if we increase
our scanning speed it would create a bad
quality image because confocal is a
point-by-point scanning method that
means it would scan your image scan your
specimen point by point and it would
reconstruct the whole image that is why
you have to use moderate to slow
scanning speed so here you can see the
speed is quite slow and the image
property is very good and the third
thing is the gain and offset of the
photo multiplier tube so you have to set
the photo multi
the tubes cane option up to a certain
level so that our image is not saturated
or our image don't have sufficient
information so it should be balanced in
such in such a manner so if we just
increase the grain in the red channel
you can see our image is oversaturated
and that is why we have to set it and
bring it to optimal settings so from
this particular video you can clearly
see the difference between the imaging
property of a confocal and a wide field
microscope I hope this video helped you
if you liked my video please subscribe
and don't forget to leave your comment
below thank you